So to implement this I’ve modified the RAN
procedure to input a parameter vector of three
parameters. And for reasons that will be obvious
later, I have a print flag that I default to false.
I have the same initial parameters as before,
speed and arrow cross stick arrow – into the
cross stick arrow, I set my fifth parameter
and to make it a little bit more obvious how
what the effect of parameter selection has on
my arrow. I also set the total number equations
to N times 2 and when I count the total cross
stick arrow, I only counted from step N 1,
so I give the algorithm a chance to convert to
zero for N steps, they don’t count the cross
stick arrow, but like to know how the cross
stick arrow evolves quite dramatically from
step 101 on to 200. If the print flag is set, I
set the output here in degrees and not in variance
and I return my average arrow before value.
So I wanted to write the routine twiddle and
the routine should find the optimal parameters
and return them to me. So I want you to
implement the twiddle with a tolerance and
threshold of 0.001. In one twiddle, it shows
the parameters over time and the cross
stick arrow. And this cross stick arrow
very quickly goes to zero. In fact after a
few iterations, 107 in my implementation
we get a cross stick arrow of 3.611 to the
minus 17th. And here is the typical control
one, you see my X, my Y, my orientation,
my drift is constant, that’s my constant
drift parameters and the beginning of the
arrows are 195 on average. But after a short
amount of time, you find that my Y arrow
goes down to 10 to the minus 6 and stays
there, which means our controller is really,
really good in tracking our desired location.
In our final control error between time step
100 and 200 is 3.611. So I wanted to
implement twiddle, we might change something
on the vowel set up, but when you run it,
it will be such that if you want a full PED
controller and find the optimal parameters
that the final control error, will be really, really
small and that’s how we’ll checking.